[音楽]
[拍手]
自分のかも早くてしたいので弾い
a
まずあの
恐怖について
僕の態度
お知らせします何かと申しますと
恐怖を避けるには恐怖を理解する必要がある
ということです
なぜそんなこというかここが怪談話をする場所ではないんです
なぜかというと僕が
こういう人間だからです
わかりますねところがこの10年
非常に大きな恐怖に2回見舞われました
一つはリーマンショックというものです
これはネットワークが無差別的に来る恐怖ですね
ね僕も web でちょっとマーケットというものに興味を持ち始めたらドーンとき
ました
そしてもう一つ311です
北は宮城県仙台市出身です
幼い頃は石巻市というところで港町で育ちました
なので非常に大きな恐怖がありましたこれはその土地に来る恐怖ですねこれはあの2つ
の恐怖というのは全く違う恐怖だと僕は思っていたんです
ところが
311というそのその土地で起こった恐怖
これは土地が奪われてそしてその土地奪われた人たちが妬ましいとなってそしてそこに
とどまることによって起こるっていう箱話はこれはもう
専用のゴシック小説日本の幽霊話いろんなとこ
のにある古典的な恐怖ですこれがまさにインターネットの時代に
またよみがえったっていうことです
んですっ
311の恐怖を古典的恐怖というふうに僕は名付けました
そして会等
リーマンショックのねネットワークの方は現在提供クト
それを僕はあの
古典鉄橋ホラーそして現代という恐怖は無差別的に瞬時に行ってきますので
テラハってこれは日本語ではテロというふうなことと同じですね
それとそれで分けて考えました
それでへ
これからお話をさせていただきますでこのあの
まず2つの恐怖
というものをまず
みなさんの想像力にちょっと多かりして
時系列的に違いを説明したいというふうに思います
まず古典的恐怖です固定的オフというのはまず
楽しい時間がありますタイガーアイポンパたりええパーティーだったりバーベキュー
だったり色んな火アソビ史観を過ごしている人たちは
見えます
夢でそこからまだまあ楽しくお子
楽しい時間を過ごしていると今度は何らかの違和感みたいなのが起こります
いつもとちょっと違うぞこれは映画とか小説ではその主人公たちは気が付かないんだ
けど読者が気がつくようななんかの違和感です
そしてそれが手術遂に登場人物だけにたちに届くようになると不安というのが徐々に
蔓延し始めますこれまだ
恐怖まで行ってませんなぜかというと恐怖というのは必ずキャラクターが出てくるから
ですそれに追っかけられたりする時に恐怖というのが起こりますこの分析はまるで
入って変わっていい人が言いました不安というのは対象がないものにをにあの起こる
ものだ
っていう風に言ったんですね誰だから不安があって
そしてついにいきます査読さんが来て蚕さんが来てジェイソンが来てフレディがきます
ねそういう時にあってそして
そして何らかのパニックが起こりますでところがここで収束がふっと訪れます
カッコカリというのはみなさんご存知ですねその後ちょっと何かあるんじゃないか
っていうところで大概はあるんですところがこの収束というのは非常に重要です
古典的恐怖というのは必ずその恐怖のキャラクターは一人です
一体です
ねっでその一帯を治めてしまう魂を鎮めるあるいは消滅させる
そういうふうにすると終わったということになります
この古典的恐怖がどうして場所というところに非常に大きな土地とか場所っていう
ところにあの
どこまあ関わるものかっていうふうになると
その
1人1体のキャラクターというのがその場所で死んでいて
その場所に固執していて
その場所でにいるのに他のものが来るから襲うという
まあこれはゴシック小説によくあるねあの話ですねそういう話が出てきます
ところが現代的おくというのが起こるようになります日本での現代提供付の走りになっ
たアノード小説あるいは映画
への着信アリという
ものですこれはともかく携帯を持ってれば場所に関わりません
突然のように行きますネットワークの恐怖です
その恐怖の場合は物語化するとこういうふうになります
楽しい時間があってというところは基本的に管理したよちょうまでだ
ここまであって一体のそのとキャラクターが
一応治るという風になった時にでもまた始まるということになります
この時重要なのは
現在撤去区の場合は例えばパンデミックが起こるとかそういうふうに
いう風に言う場合には何故か知らないけど多数のキャラクターになっていたりします
つまり一体で治らない
っていう考え方になるししかもその土地から出て
パンデミックですからどんどん広がっていくという形になりますこれがあの着信アリだ
と携帯電話
というところで表現されるようになりました
でこの2つというところがやっぱりとても道
僕が10年間に
ねあの道恐怖を感じた時に
時系列パターンかでしてみたらまああのこういうパターンになるだろうなというふうに
思ったことです
ではなぜ
巨古典的恐怖だけにとどまらずに現代提供風になっていくのか
僕はメディア論なのでメディア史的なお話をちょこっとさせていただきます
まず土地から離れるっていうことになります
これは携帯電話を持つということもそうですね実はこれは重要なのは
重要なのはもともとそのメディアっていう言葉に
ポイントがあります僕がどうしてこちらにの方
考え出したかと言いますとメディアっていう言葉あればメディウムですね最初
媒体とか言います媒介とか言います
実はこれの古い言葉に冷媒ということもあります
簡単にいうとこれは全部まとめるとあちらとこちらをつなぐっていうことですね
彼方つこちらをつなぐっていうのはもともと場所に考えられていました
神乳車
そういうところですね教会も含めますねそういう場所でした
その場所が
あちらとこちらをつなぐトークを近くに近づけるっていうものは
実は技術革新によってメディアっていうものになっていきます
最初は映画館だったり
ねそれが今度は8テレビになってお茶の間に入っていきます
マジですね
だから貞子さんはテレビからできますねそしてあの
そして今度は携帯のようです
ねそういう風になって行った時にだんだん単なる場所ではなくて体にフィットしてくる
今井字ことがありますねううぇ r ブルーになってきます恐怖もウェアラブルですね
そうなってきてどこでも井戸になる可能になりますそうすると
今まではどっかの土地が打とう恐怖の対象でしたからその土地から逃げればいいという
話がありました
この土地に拘らなければいいところがそうではなくなりますね
常に自分の自分のポケットにありますから
どこにいようがちゃんと
ねあの友達のようについていきますねそれでこういう風な特徴になります
現代的恐怖の特徴はまず場所をとらなくなります
そして無差別に襲いかかってきますつまりグローバル化ということは恐怖もグローバル
化することです
そして進退に瞬時に作用します前だったらば遠くからやってくるぞやってくるぞって
いうキャラクターだったのがいきなり
ストーンここから行ってきますそういう風になってきますだから
テラー
というふうに僕は命名しました
これが一応歴史的な特徴だと思ってください
猫の特徴っていうものを
この特徴を
がですねメディアがますますスマホを思い出してい
ますます小型化してくるとこのスマホだけじゃあ足りなくなってくるんです
今ホームから転落したりいろんな事故がありますね
スマホを持っているということはどういうことかというと僕らはその
ねテラーが来るの待ち構えるモニターを見ながらですね
進んでいくとその横の方の
世界が全部死角になってしまう
ということは無理ターンを見ていてもモニターの外文字世界もすべて
ね死角になって未来が襲ってくるという考え方になります
これが a
非常に危ないねこれを僕らはおそらくリスク社会というのでしょうね
そういうところになっているとまず考えてくださいで今僕がお話したのは時系列的に来
ずーっとなるとこうなりますよという話でしたーじゃあ実は恐怖というのは物語で語ら
れるということは直線
の時間近大が作った時間ですけれどもこの直線の時間っていうとに従ってやってきます
ところがこれをバラバラにしてみると意外と大丈夫
っていうことがわかりますなぜそれがわかったかというと
僕がやっぱりそういう恐怖が嫌いだということがわかったときに
スズキコージさんリングを作った方ですね
この人のお話を聞いたら面白かったんです
自分の小説は怖いですかって聞いた時にや全然怖くない自分が作ったものだから
っていう風に言ったんですね所おっしゃっています
でそれを聞いたときにあぁそうか
つまり作り手というのはある本品なら本映画な映画というところに
パターンを最初から知っていて
そのパターンをこうやって並べることによって時間の時間に並べることによって相手を
怖がらせるということをします
ところが受け手の方はそのパターンを知らないですから
知っていてもなんとなくその時間にうまくコーンの乗っていないといけません
今のみなさんもそうですね僕僕も
半分くらいはそうですねそういうふうにしていくとその時間にこう上手くド操縦される
ようにして
重要してしまいますね
ね恐怖というのはそうやってきますということは鈴木康師さんのようになれば
ちょっと軽減できるかもしれない
って考えたわけですつまり恐怖のパターンを乱そうと言って僕はこの7年間くらいで
36のパターンを見出しました
ただしここであのここであろーんと
紹介する紹介するパターンは6つだけです皆さんが方って言ってくれる守る基本的に
日本のものを
ねあの含みます
まずパターンですパターンに分解してみるとこうなります
ストーリーに待って変わりません
ねパターンに分解するとまずドアの鍵はいつも空いています
音なのに入ると二度と出られません
こうなりますねまるでブラックホールのようですねそういう家になっておりますまた
わざわざ登場人物がですね自分でその部屋のドアをまた閉めてしまったりします
そうするともう自業自得という空間になりますねでこれは多分みなさんの想像力でを
担っていただけるとわかる
と思いますそして次ですね
水平移動する時は比較的安全なんです
ところが垂直に移動するしようとすると非常に危険になります
簡単に言えば一番重要なのはエレベーターと屋根裏なんですが特に日本の場合は英霊
エレベーターに特に一人で乗ってしまうともう終了します
ね屋根裏に行こうとするとなんかいます
で西洋の場合は地下室では非常に重要なポイントになります
これはやはり8宗教者やなんかっていうのは基本的には放浪するっていう物語と暮らす
ねどっかに上るとかどこかに下るという話が非常に多いですね
それによってい買いにつながっているっていう風に油はしますつまり人間の考え方って
いう
いうところを上手く利用しているということですね移動の時の音でその次です
水に関わる場所はなぜかとても危ない
つまりトイレバスルームキッチンというのは非常に危ない場所としてみられますこれは
日本的な恐怖です
で
特にだじゃあどこが一番最凶か分かりますね
ワンルームマンションです
万両マンションはすべてここにつながっていますから
だから尚更そこに村が舞台になった場合はもう大変な恐怖を保護であの味わうことに
なります
こういうふうに見てみるとわかりますねじゃあその次今度は身につける場合になります
だんだんミニ
ウェアラブルになってきますから
白い服を着ている人はすでにこの世界にいないかあるいはこれからいなくなるという
ことがわかりますこれは男性はちょっと違います男性は何着ててもダメです
女性の場合は基本的に白い服になるとこうなりますこれは冠婚葬祭の服の色見てれば
大体わかりますね
白い服を着るって言うところはね仕事いうのはもともと日本語では印っていう言葉から
きているらしいです
知るシートなあちらの世界の
長江っていう意味ですだからしろというのはあちらの世界はれますと
ということですねねそしてその次ですね
写真の顔が切り抜かれていたり傷つけられたりしていたらその人はこの世界にいないか
あるいはこれからいなくなりますねこれは写真というのも一つのメディアでしたけれど
もそれこそ子にある実態実証とか写実っていう考え方でこの世界を結構強く意識させる
ものを
穴が開いているということはあちらの世界というふうになります
そしてさっき言ったようなやつですね電話やテレビというものはですねほらあるいは
テラーの映画には
この世界につながったり別の世界につながったりします
この世界でを誰かと喋ってるなと思ったら別の世界で
しゃべねしゃべしゃべ別の世界から9人どうメッセージが来たりしますね
ねこういうふうにバラバラにしてみるとないと面白いです後は家の逆食と水の脚色が
どうなっているかカー3というのはどういう役割を果たしているかねあとは後に
尿というのは使い方はせようと東洋は違うぞとか色んなパターンなんですがそれは今回
は省略させていただきます
で皆さんに考えてほしいのはこっからです
ここから
もし主人公がこのパターンをあらかじめ知っていたらどうなりますかということです
ねっ
鍵が開いて書いている部屋に入ろうとしたら
ねあれこれ行くともうもう出らんねーなと思ったらやめるでしょう
ねえとかホラーになりません
姉あやねうらに行けっていう命令が何かありそうだ
やめようえっていう風になればもうなりませんね
つまりそこで恐怖は拡散にされるはずです
僕らがパターンということを少し考える
これは経験値を上げるとかなとかっていうのはありますけれどもそういう考え方のが実
はとても重要なんですね
でこの主人公はランダムなじしょんは集まる世界でパターンを抽出しながら進んで行っ
ているって事になりますこれは直線的な
過去現在未来を行くんではなくて最初から
せ
はランダムだって言ってこう広げて拾っているっていうことです
でこの主人公は恐怖を最小化しようとしています
そして生きる喜びとか楽しみっても最大化しようとしてそういう風にして試行錯誤を
繰り返すからジグザグに行きます
だから直線には館関わらないような生き方
倒しているということですそうするとどういう
どういう考えになるか
現在はリスク社会と呼ばれておりますこのリスク社会っていうのがリスクっていう語源
はもともと高い崖のが崖のあるたニューを
船が
帆掛け船が香堂進様を言ったそうです
そしてその進様っていうのいうのがねあった場合には昔の人はそこで星座とかそういう
ものを見たんですねまぁそれで方向を決めようとしたその星座というのは何か
ランダムな
捕手という事象の中に何かパターンを見出したんです
そうすることによって外に出ようとしていた
だからこのパターンは実は今コンピューターもやっていることです
このランダムの事象からパターンを見出して来た僕らはどう思う
コンピューターに非常にあの
頼りきりのようですだから僕らもこういう考え方をしていけばもしかしたら恐怖は最小
化するかもしれません
ありがとうございます
ちなみにもう
夜になっておりますのでねこっからを偉人を編音出られる方は
パターンを選んでくださいじゃあはあります
[拍手]